today we are checking out the brand new
dji osmo
action this is super exciting this was
just announced by dji
and what's really cool about this is it
has dual screens there's a screen on the
front
and one on the back
it shoots 4k hdr and it also has this
really cool mode called rocksteady so
that'll allow you to get those
gimbal-like shots
using electronic image stabilization and
it also shoots 4k 60 and it's waterproof
up to 11 meters so you don't need any
external housing
it's waterproof just as it is i'll be
traveling over the next week testing
this thing out but first we have to
unbox it
[Music]
so first inspection of this it does look
a lot like a gopro
so here's the place for a battery and
one of the things that i've already
kind of noticed is it looks like this
battery slot is a lot bigger than gopro
instructions look at this cute little
case for a battery
so here's the battery and that just goes
right in here
so over here is an sd card slot and also
a usb
c port power button our display button
and we've got another little quick shot
button
right over here let's turn it on so the
back is touch screen
got the apple here click to connect
we're activating the camera now download
the firmware
and then we'll take a look and see what
else we have here we've also got these
two mounts
we've got this little rectangular one in
this circular one and just has a little
sticky film so you can just put these
and mount them to anything
looks like we've got a usbc cable and
the little screw that you'll use to
mount your camera
to those mounts one thing that is great
is if you do have any gopro accessories
whether they're made by gopro or any
third-party accessories
this little mount looks like it will
work with all of those
you're basically set and ready to go hey
our firmware is updating
whoa yes it is happening everything is
awesome so here's the app we've got time
lapse
slow motion we have hdr video we've also
got regular video and we've got a photo
so i'm just going to take a picture real
quick here using the app
the quick switch button this gives us
quick access
to switching between all of the
different shooting modes so one of the
cool things about this is it does have a
front screen
on it so if you are filming yourself and
trying to get different angles
especially if you have this mounted in
some sort of weird position
it's really hard to be able to see what
you're shooting if you want to use the
front screen all you have to do is
double tap with two fingers
and voila you can now see yourself or
see whatever it is that you're shooting
in the front screen
i am really excited about this camera
i'm just going to hit record and see
what we got
oh my gosh i'm recording and i see
myself in the front screen this is so
neat this is so crazy
like look at this
wow so now this is unboxed and set up
that means we can go outside and test it
out
[Music]
do you see yourself yeah isn't this
crazy
so it's a little bit windy so the audio
probably is struggling a little bit but
this
is man i am loving this thing so much
i just shot a quick little time lapse
i'm not sure how it turned out because
we didn't want to go all the way down
there to get the really good shot
because it's kind of cold and it's
raining
good thing this thing is waterproof
hey jen hi i was eating my peanut butter
packets
we are here in palos verdes it's so
beautiful like look at this oh my gosh
spring half frong people it has sprung
i'm not using the rocksteady right now
this is just the normal 4k
it is so beautiful we've come here so
many times and i've never seen it i've
never seen it like this i'm also very
jealous of this
it's like super this camera is really
great okay i'm gonna flip it on to
rocksteady and see what that looks like
i keep looking at the front-facing
camera though instead of where i need to
look at the lens
bad habit it's as tall as me
now this is with rocksteady on and
already i can tell just by looking at it
that the stabilization is
really awesome it does crop in slightly
but honestly
for this type of stabilization and you
already have a super wide angle lens
it looks really great
i almost fell
[Music]
there's the sunset the clouds kind of
came in and we we missed it but
oh well now we're going to go to dinner
so stay tuned for some really great food
content it's kind of dark in there i
don't know if you were able to see it
well we just have a little bit that's
true we are now at dinner i'm so excited
this is one of my favorite places we're
in manhattan beach this place is called
love and salt if you guys like pasta
and you happen to be anywhere near this
place go to it
they also have really good pizza i got
some spaghetti that's pretty dark in
here but
there it is the kale salad and that's
the end
of this segment of the video move on
do
[Music]
so i am now in new york and i was here
for youtube's brandcast they have all
kinds of creators come out and lots of
brands and advertisers and all kinds of
fun stuff
but i had a really fun week but now i
have some free time so of course
the first thing that i'm gonna do is i'm
going to test out this camera
and as you can see i just tested out
some slow-mo
going through those doors i'm on my way
right now to find a yerba mate it's that
drink that you guys are always like
justin what is that that you're drinking
well this is what it is and hopefully i
can find one
i use their store locator and they show
that there was this market that had it
there it is i want you guys to go in the
comments right now it's a good luck
justine
cuz we're going in that's not what i was
looking for
maybe they've got more back here i have
never been so sad in all of my
days i've definitely been sadder but
that just means i have to find a place
to get one
what this okay so this is like a it's a
sparkling one
i think i should get both of them into a
taste test
[Music]
this is disgusting and this was like the
last drink on earth like if i was on
like my deathbed though
this is what you have to drink to stay
alive i don't even know if i could do it
[Music]
it's so terrible we gotta go to whole
foods hey justine you went to new york
to do a camera review what did you do
i was searching for canned yerba mate
what a great video
classic
[Music]
this search is getting real just uber to
whole foods
it's been such a long journey to get
here i'd like to thank my friends my
family i like thank you guys i would
like to thank your vamante i'd like to
thank dji for making this incredible
awesome action
right now if you can't tell we're using
the rocksteady so everything is super
super smooth and i'm gonna go and check
out now
[Music]
i plan on getting some really great
shots today for you well guess what
it's raining good thing that the awesome
action is waterproof
[Music]
i had mentioned previously that the osmo
action is in fact waterproof up to 11
meters so we're going to test that out
we're not going to go 11 meters
we're probably not even gonna go more
than three feet to be honest with you
because i don't actually like to go
underwater so
hey i'm a mask i've got action and we're
going to go in and
test it out it's also very cold today so
just keep that in mind
we're recording in 4k30 we're using
rocksteady because it's my favorite mode
i hate going out of water
wow i should have got you the snorkel i
should have got sparkle
so graceful
you guys make fun of me for saying like
of course you could swim
i absolutely can
that was a really super pathetic attempt
at swimming so now we're gonna try again
in 4k
60 frames a second
look how far i went
[Music]
okay well i think you guys get the point
it's waterproof
i think next time i need to find
somebody who can actually swim or do
underwater activities because i am not
that person i offered you my underwater
scooter
next time so i'm gonna try to get a
sunset time lapse except it's raining
outside so i don't think i'm gonna get
much of a sunset
but this is the little setup that i have
right here i have it connected to a
battery charger so i'm just gonna leave
this for
several hours and see what happens ready
let's go so i have this set to taking
infinity photos so basically this is
going to last until the sd card fills up
or this nimble charger dies see you in a
few hours little time lapse
[Music]
so i'm back after about two and a half
hours the time lapse is still going and
i'm so excited about it that i think i'm
gonna just keep it
running until tomorrow we're gonna get a
sunset to sunrise if this all works out
[Music]
this is a little editor's note i'm
actually working on this video right now
i just wanted you guys to know that this
time lapse went for about 15
hours i am so impressed with how awesome
it turned out let me know what you guys
think in the comments below
[Music]
start recording
oh my gosh yeah you don't have to say
it's name
no it will just start recording that's
actually the first time i tried that but
wait there's more
what else is there you can say stop
recording
yes take photo is that the right command
let me see take a photo take a photo
screen switch yeah
this is so great what happens if i say
it from far away
good stop recording it stop
we are going on a road trip and i'm
testing out the osmo
action here and one of my favorite
things is the voice control screen
switch
how does it work it's like magic screen
oh good at all there it goes start
recording oh
my goodness get out isn't it great
stop recording take a photo
that's the future well it's no it's now
oh my god
[Music]
wow
yeah yeah you want a race
oh my god that's amazing we're testing
this out i turned rocksteady off
so i'm gonna show you guys how
stabilized this was previously
and how stabilized it's not now
so nervous guys this is super dangerous
you absolutely should
you should do this
[Music]
i don't know this side right
i think i think
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
so this isn't slo-mo it's just moving
very slow
[Music]
um should we play some games maybe
yeah let's do that we want a large prize
so all we do is win win win
no matter what
[Music]
oops
i got three we are super skilled
you weren't even paying attention i
wasn't
yay thank you
[Music]
so
you guys don't want to ride it with me
yeah i don't want to leave you at all
[Music]
me
this is not as fun as i thought it was
going to be
oh my gosh
there's a lot more movement on this ride
that i was ready for i did not like it
so much
i can't
[Laughter]
thank you i almost threw up five times
yeah
i'm so sorry oh i'm dizzy should we sit
down yeah
we what do we do now
[Music]
oh my heavenly
oh god oh it doesn't it doesn't stop it
doesn't stop it doesn't stop when you um
it doesn't it's a very very poor design
it's a very poor design
very poor design
[Music]
yes that's it uh make sure you guys go
check out farook's channel
i am such a huge fan and thank you so
much for coming over of course thanks so
much for having new dji osmo
action what's your favorite feature
about it i really like
the front screen you cannot really see
everything but it gives you an idea
about your frame and it changes the game
a lot
thank you guys for watching if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you give it
a thumbs up and be sure to subscribe
hit the bell whatever else it is that
you do on youtube i don't know run
around a few circles maybe by that time
they'll put a new thing in there
probably
hit the bell pull the carpet
let's go burn more things
[Music]